locate unsc infinity
class super carrier crow size 7150
not found
near field perimeter scan 1986
unsc tags detected status deceased
the master chief lives
atriox assured us of his death
are you not anger do you know
i feel
invigorated
you promised us revenge
superiority
he threatens everything do you question
my leadership atriox
is dead
it is his fault that we are stuck here
the feminist will never bow
to anyone
again
not the covenant
not the products
not
her
this ring will be operational
[Music]
follow a spartan from a distance
i want to know everything about him
attempting decryption
decryption failed
locate message source triangulation in
progress
we're done my chief
if we stay out here any longer they're
gonna come back
they'll find us and they'll kill us
what is it you're searching for
signal located
uploading there's nothing there
you're looking in the wrong direction
we need to go
home plot the waypoint requesting manual
flight control override do it autopilot
engage wait what
are you kidding me
why would we go down there
the banish plan to wipe us out all of us
then what
you think we can stop them on our own
i told you
we lost
we need help
not heroics
no we do our duty
protect humanity whatever the cost
i can't be the only every atmosphere
[Music]
a weapon
how many guns do you need
what is wrong with you remind me to
never pick up
person terrible idea
this
this
they're coming for us
all of them
okay
no
yeah
uh
more reinforcements this weapon of yours
must be worth it
each ring is different
i see an entry point in the wall ahead
right
be careful they're still coming
you really pissed them off back there
[Music]
look at this place
it's beautiful
and broken
very very broken
i need to move there are ships
everywhere
to see
[Music]
trapped
[Music]
we knew
is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
if you knew how you were going to die
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
get away
oh
what are those things this is four on
the right
i've heard the stories but man
this is crazier than i imagined
don't question
how do you know this isn't a trap
i don't
great
i hope this weapon of yours is worth a
risk
i'm reading multiple enemy ships heading
this way too many
it's been six months where have you been
what happened
where is cortana
the rogue ai known as cortana is gone
she's been deleted
how
by you
of course not
did you hit your head or something
don't you remember my instructions were
to enter this installation imitate
cortana and lock her down for retrieval
yours were to take her back to the
infinity for deletion
so if it wasn't you
okay then
there's something else
on successful deployment my deletion
routine was supposed to complete
still here
good
good
my programming failed i'm not supposed
to be here you need to delete me
no
no
i was created for one purpose and that
purpose is no longer needed my mission
is over we have a new one
the banished are planning to fire this
ring we need to make sure they don't
first of all
what's a banished
second you may have noticed that a
significant piece of this installation
has been damaged making that impossible
and third to fire this ring they would
need an activation index
cortana had the index i had parts of it
as well something stopped your deletion
we need to find out why
but
this wasn't the mission the missions
changed
they always do
are you sure
did you do that
no removing me triggered a response from
the ring
i need you to understand
how would you live your
life differently
that voice
is cortana's
no it's not her
just dust and echoes what did you say
what it's just pieces of data cycling
until they run out of
power it's all around us
today
i was
called an emotionless
they saw faces
75 healthy subjects
hand-picked
mostly
there is one subject that i find myself
hoping does live through this he is
perfectly suited for what is coming
he has been assigned a number
there's something up ahead i can feel it
calling out to me
these are the banished
affirmative
they smell even worse than i imagined
you can
smell them
well an array of sensors in your armor
cam and i analyze the input
you smell fine by the way
look over there that's the source
the bridge is out
yes it is
maybe there's a way to power it back up
nearby
me
is it safe
i think so
yes
it's safe
yes
this is
part of me
i don't know why
i don't know how but it is me
it was the last part i remember being
deleted
let me just
you are here because you were chosen
our enemies are getting smarter and more
numerous every day
what i am about to show you will help
turn the tide of war
i have been working to harness the
strategic power of a ship born ai onto
the battlefield
are you ready
yes
dr halsey
unlike previous ai models she will
reside between your mind and the suit
directly communicating with your neural
interface
think of her as a new set of eyes to aid
your reactions
and upgrade your reconnaissance
she's not the driver
but a way to level the playing field
what do i call her ask her
she named herself
hello master chief
i'm cortana
together you become our newfound hope
together you become our key to
humanity's survival
she will do anything necessary to make
sure that your mission is accomplished
even if that means sacrificing herself
or you
to accomplish it
what happened
i touched it and
was that real
it's just data
it's
it's just here
clusters of recursive code
but this on the other hand
this is the framework i use to trap
cortana
it contains a copy of the activation
index at least fragments of it
what should we do with it
do we need it
well based on what you've told me so far
the bigger question is do the banished
need it
do it
that was
something
let's go
did i miss something there's a fight but
i don't have access
we need a route out of here
okay let's see there's a breach close by
it should lead us to the surface
give me a second and i'll get this
bridge activated
we've got company chief meet me at the
plinth up ahead
surprise humans
[Music]
[Applause]
we lost one
how you got here fast
not the type to waste any time huh no
noted let's go
god
in here
even in my darkest moments when i feel
the most
[Applause]
of the lies
of secrets in this forsaken ring
atriox hear me
your will is absolute
oh no
what's wrong
this gravity lift should be powered up
we need to find a way to bring it back
online
this object
it's part of the ring's life force
it's called a power seed
all space all times
the
stop how is is that a spartan we need to
find
she was carrying an enhanced shield
module
let's see what i can find out about her
accessing
this is spartan bonita stone recon
specialist
her vitals have been offline for nearly
a month
cause of death was an energy blade but
different stronger
a single strike she never saw it coming
we're here that elevator should take us
to the surface
[Music]
oh
ah
right
we need to call down the elevator
look for a control terminal
this elevator is drawing power from the
ring
well it was the seed is missing
what are these things
genetic repositories forerunner storage
vessels
cylixes
how do you know this
i was stuck in that room for six months
that should do it let's get back to the
elevator
this is
[Applause]
forced me to help them with it
whatever it is
they brought it up from
whatever's below
when it opened
god it was
something different
i've never seen anything like
it's not my fault
this isn't forerunner it identifies as
banished
can you operate it in my sleep
not that i sleep but
oh
i don't need to
it's already on its way down
incoming
but
what if it's a friend
it isn't
he did not specify
in how many pieces
[Music]
you for that
queens
oh
good
but not good
enough cheers
[Music]
me
oh
you were right he was not friendly by
the looks of him he was some sort of
leader they called him tremonius
not anymore
that's almost funny
sierra sierra 117 understood
i've been trying to reach you you
vanished
i thought i was on my
okay i got your location
on my way be ready
you